[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero el
17 de junio de 1972 hace exactamente 50
años cinco personas fueron detenidas por
intentar robar en la sede del partido
demócrata situada en el complejo
watergate un evento sin aparente
importancia que sin embargo ocultaba una
realidad mucho mayor el espionaje por
parte del equipo de campaña del
presidente richard nixon a sus rivales
políticos en la crónica de historia de
esta semana repasamos cómo fue el
escándalo político más importante de la
historia de eeuu en junio de 1972 apenas
faltaban unos meses para las elecciones
de noviembre en las que el presidente
republicano richard nixon buscaba la
reelección frente al demócrata george
mcgovern es en este contexto en el que
en la madrugada del 17 de junio cinco
personas fueron detenidas por allanar
las instalaciones del partido demócrata
al caso apenas se le dio importancia
pero empezó a llamar la atención de dos
jóvenes periodistas del washington post'
llamados bob woodward y carl bernstein
para estos dos periodistas era llamativo
que entre los cinco detenidos estuviera
james mccarthy un antiguo miembro de la
cia y jefe de seguridad para la campaña
de reelección de nixon las
investigaciones se centraron en
averiguar la relación de estas personas
con los conocidos como hombres del
presidente' figuras cercanas a nixon que
tenían un gran poder en este proceso fue
fundamental la ayuda de algunos
funcionarios entre los que destaca el
confidente conocido como 'garganta
profunda' un miembro de la cúpula del
fbi que años más tarde se descubriría
como mark felt las investigaciones
arrojaron luz sobre una campaña de
espionaje orquestada desde la casa
blanca que tenía la finalidad de conocer
todo sobre los rivales políticos del
presidente nixon esta información sería
útil para atacarlos y extorsionarlos y
facilitaría la reelección un escándalo
que llegó a las portadas del 'washington
post' en septiembre de 1972 pero que
apenas tuvo relevancia mediática de
hecho richard nixon obtuvo una victoria
aplastante en las presidenciales de
noviembre y fue reelegido pero el caso
no moriría aquí ya que en el juicio
contra los cinco detenidos se revelaría
información importante sobre el
escándalo en enero de 1973 los cinco
acusados se declararon culpables de los
cargos de robo y allanamiento pero uno
de ellos james mccord decidió enviarle
una carta a la jueza encargada del caso
asegurando que había recibido presiones
y amenazas a su familia para que se
declarara culpable unas palabras que sí
llamaron la atención de toda la prensa
estadounidense y que levantaron las
sospechas durante los meses siguientes
la presión al entorno de la
administración nixon aumentó hasta que
el congreso decidió abrir una
investigación sobre lo sucedido una
cuestión que hizo reaccionar a nixon que
se vio obligado a despedir a algunos de
los altos cargos políticos que lo
rodeaban afirmando que habían sido
renuncia
hoy en una de las decisiones más
difíciles de mi presidencia
acepte las renuncias de dos de mis
asociados más cercanos en la casa
blanca- gob ademán y jon aritz man dos
de los mejores servidores públicos que
he tenido el privilegio de conocer
profesional pero estas personas al
sentirse traicionadas decidieron revelar
que el mandatario grababa todas las
conversaciones que mantenía en el
despacho oval la cuestión de estos
audios se volvió un tema prioritario
para conocer si la casa blanca estaba o
no involucrada en el escándalo watergate
la tensión se elevó cuando la corte
suprema de eeuu solicitó al presidente
que entregara esas grabaciones y éste se
negó causando un conflicto institucional
sin precedentes para esa época tras
varias negativas nixon entregó de forma
parcial las cintas y después de que se
descubriera que aún faltaban grabaciones
se vio obligado a entregar la totalidad
del contenido lo revelado en los audios
fue un escándalo de proporciones
históricas
nixon no solamente a bien expirar al
partido demócrata sino que durante el
inicio de las investigaciones del caso
watergate trató de usar a la cia para
torpedear cualquier indagación que
pudiera hacer sobre el tema el fbi esta
cuestión hizo que perdiera el apoyo de
su propio partido y que se iniciará un
proceso de impeachment que finalmente no
se ejecutó ya que richard nixon dimitió
como presidente el 8 de agosto de 1974
nunca he sido un desertor dejaré el
cargo antes de que termine mi mandato es
abominable para todos los instintos de
mi cuerpo
pero como presidente debo anteponer el
interés de eeuu
por lo tanto renunciaré a la presidencia
a partir del mediodía de mañana el
vicepresidente ford prestará juramento
como presidente a esa hora en esta
oficina
en eso vamos
a pesar de todo nixon no enfrentó ningún
cargo ya que un mes después fue
indultado por su sucesor el
vicepresidente gerald ford aunque en
total hasta el 48 personas del entorno
del presidente fueron condenadas a
diferentes penas de prisión el escándalo
watergate fue uno de los episodios
políticos más destacados en eeuu e hizo
que richard nixon fuera y siga siendo el
único presidente que ha dimitido en toda
la historia de su país por su parte bob
woodward y carl bernstein recibieron el
premio pulitzer y demostraron la
importancia que tiene el periodismo
independiente como mecanismo de control
en una democracia con esto concluimos
gracias por compartir y comentar estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de france 24 punto com
[Música]